la conférence de presse de la Transat
Jacques Vabre 2023 vient tout juste de
se terminer deux équipages ivinois
seront au départ de l'épreuve il y aura
notamment Louis Burton et David Baudard
qui seront sur cette transat jacqu Vabre
2023 Louis Burton qui est rambolitin et
did baudar qui vientent un peu plus loin
par contre alors Louis Burton qu'est-ce
que ça fait d'être sur cette 7e transat
Java personnellement et ben bonjour à
tous c'est un rêve qui se réalise une
fois de plus prendre le départ des
courses c'est déjà une grande aventure
parce qu'on a des bateaux très
compliqués il faut se préparer se
qualifier puis je pars avec did qui est
un grand champion et et en plus un ami
donc voilà ça va être un moment un
moment formidable et puis on peut relier
rambouiller la Bretagne voilà on en est
la preuve vivante Davy ça vous fait quoi
de partir pour la troisième fois avec
Louis Burton et bien je suis très
heureux que Louis m'accorde une fois de
plus sa confiance lui et toute l'équipe
B Racing ainsi que bureau Vallé et moi
j'adore adore naviguer avec lui j'arrête
pas de lui dire c'est mon binôme au-delà
de de l'aventure sportive il y a
l'aventure humaine et je crois qu'on est
pas mal sur ce niveaulà alors vous allez
partir sur bureau Vallé 3 comment il est
le bateau ben c'est un bateau assez
récent puisque c'est un bateau qui date
de 2020 juste avant le précédent vent
des globes là au défi azimut le bateau
était encore 4e à une seconde au niveau
vitesse des des trois premiers donc
c'est un bateau qui reste d'actualité
qui a été amélioré cet hiver sur lequel
on va mettre des voiles neuves et
retailler et repenser suite à
l'expérience qu'on a avec le bateau donc
voilà c'est c'est sûr qu'avec 40 40 duo
une dizaine de bateau neuf ça va ça va
être très engagé sportivement mais mais
on a encore de quoi jouer devant du coup
cette course transatlantique on l'a
compris se dispute en duo quels sont les
clés pour pas se marcher dessus
peut-être dans le
bateau en fait c'est assez simple moi je
m'occupe de de tout le bateau dehors et
puis Louis à l'intérieur il gère il gère
il gère la navigation non en fait en
course en double sur ce genre de bateau
c'est avant tout deux solitaires on
passe un peu de temps tous les deux mais
on est à beaucoup de moments on est tout
seul on gère le bateau et les bateour
sont quand même assez grands pour pas se
marcher dessus
et ça se passe très bien en fait
oui tu confirmes il y a une bonne
répartition des rôles au sein du bateau
ouais c'est un gros avantage de bien se
connaître d'avoir beaucoup navigué
ensemble avec des vies euh quand l'un se
repose il faut quand même bien sûr être
capable de gérer le bateau complètement
et euh le côté agréable c'est d'essayer
de faire les choses en commun au maximum
donc si dvis s'occupe de la météo et de
la stratégie il m'en parle si c'est moi
qui m'en occupe je lui en parle et on
essaie de prendre les décisions ensemble
et puis après parfois aussi en fonction
du feeling il y en a un qui va vouloir
attaquer plus que l'autre et cetera donc
voilà il faut réussir à être dans le
dialogue au maximum pas être chacun dans
son coin et euh c'est aussi ça bien
s'entendre sur une jacevabre et ça peut
grâce à ça faire parfois des des
étincelles alors on le rappelle C
transat jacevabre se déroule entre Le
Havre et la Martinique quels sont les
pièges à éviter sur cette course
transatlantique alors le départ du HAV
c'est déjà un endroit compliqué c'est
assez reculé dans la Manche donc à cette
période ben on a des dépressions qui
arrivent de l'Atlantique qui peuvent
boucher un petit peu la la sortie de la
Manche c'est étroit donc là il y a des
cargos des bateaux de pêche du courant
très fort donc ça c'est un gros piège
déjà il peut se passer plein de choses
on avait eu des déboirs d'ailleurs dans
cette zone il y a 2 ans la sortie du
golf de démage ouais avec un démattage
tout à fait sortie du golf de Gascogne
zone compliquée aussi parce que bah il y
a les systèmes météo viennent et ben
sans qu'ill est comme ça entre la France
et l'Espagne donc c'est un peu bloquant
puis après une fois qu'on est sorti de
là on arrive dans la lysée plus ou moins
vite donc là on est poussé par le vent
et puis là ils nous font faire une
petite blague ils nous font descendre un
peu dans le poteau noir donc la zone où
le vent est pas très clair et et on va
rester un peu dedans et puis après il
faut qu'on ressorte dans l'Ouest et
qu'on arrive à retourner la Martinique
vers la Martinique pardon donc ça c'est
un ouais c'est un défi de réussir à ce
que ça se passe bien dans cette zone là
là normalement il va se passer pas mal
de choses j'imagine d qu'il faudra bien
communiquer à C dans ces moments clés
euh bien sûr en fait même bien analysé
en amont toutes ces phases prédépart la
première semaine qui va être sûrement la
plus compliquée l'arrivée sur le poteau
noir la fin de course au portant en
arrivant sur la Martin non il faut
anticiper on communiquera forcément
beaucoup tous les deux et deux cerveaux
sont beaucoup plus forts qu'un seul donc
on prendra forcément les bonnne décision
si je me trompe pas Louis tu as fait au
mieux 5e sur cette transat jackvab
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un objectif de
podium cette année ou de victoire alors
on est on est dans une
philosophie complètement différente il
faut avoir en tête que quand je termine
5e de la JAC Vabre il y avait 15 bateaux
au départ là on va être 40 bateaux au
départ il y a beaucoup de plus de bâton
UF et on est aussi dans une perspective
de de d'approche du vent des globes et
sur laquelle on travaille déjà depuis
depuis plusieurs années avec DESV et
avec le reste de l'équipe bureau Vallé
donc on veut essayer d'être le plus
performant possible mais on veut avant
tout terminer la course c'est très
important quelques jours après l'arrivée
de la jacevabre il va y avoir une autre
course qui va repartir dans l'autre sens
qui est très importante aussi dans le
cadre de la préparation au vent des
globes donc grosso modo on va mettre
plein gaz mais on va essayer de savoir
lever le pied quand il faudra oui ça
sera l'occasion aussi de tester encore
une nouvelle fois ton bateau j'imagine
ouais là là on en est plus au stade du
test on en est stade de fiabiliser et et
d'être sûr en effet que les décisions
les choix qu'on a pu prendre sont les
bons dans un an on est on sera au départ
du vend desglobes donc voilà maintenant
faut être sûr et le vend desglobes
forcément c'est un objectif ouais le
vend des globes c'est c'est un objectif
important dans la classe imoka c'est
c'est hyper important ça l'
proportionnellement moins de manière
moins impressionnante qu'avant parce que
toutes les autres courses sont tirées
vers le haut avec beaucoup de
participants mais oui le tour du monde
ça reste un objectif très important
sportivement et puis pour les
partenaires pour toute la vie du projet
mais avant ce vend des Glob il y a cette
transat ja qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter à tous les deux avant de de
prendre le
départ du plaisir beaucoup
et et qu'on arrive en bonne forme de
l're côté bonne forme et pas trop loin
de des premiers ce serait pas mal merci
à tous les deux la Transat jackvab 2023
le départ sera donné le 29 octobre
depuis Le Havre